but after every school shooting
Republicans come out and go no no no
don't don't do do anything about the
assault weapons the guns are more
important than the kids assault weapons
are not an actual thing mass shootings
are under the decline gun control
measures at large have actually proven
to be not effective in reducing violent
crime guns save Millions more lives than
they ever take according to the FBI
anywhere from 200,000 to 3 million plus
the Second Amendment ensures your right
to self-preservation including firearms
and by the way you're an for
exploiting senseless tragedy to try and
forcibly strip us of our human rights
regard regardless